[Music]
[Applause]
the negro leagues
were benefactor of world war ii in a
secondary way
the war broadened the mindset and opened
up an opportunity
for white americans to see that perhaps
we need to make the field level here
the major leagues were supposed to be
the best but then the major league teams
would get beaten by a team that had all
black people on it
people that supposed to be inferior they
knew they
had to break that barrier
newspapers and newspaper writers very
important because they were always
telling the story especially black
publications
they were responsible for documenting
this history
that you didn't read about hear about in
national news it was really in our black
newspaper
and one of those i want to salute is sam
lacy
sam lacy is outside of my father the
biggest influence in my life
i think one of the most important
journalists in the annals of american
journalistic history
he's international baseball hall of
fame's writer's wing he was at every
major sporting event
in america he became the voice of black
baseball
sam had a unique writing style you
couldn't look past
the truth that was in sam lacy's stories
one of his quotes was
all men are created equal but some men
are created more equal than others
and that was his definition of white
privilege sam lacy was
very instrumental in getting major
league baseball to integrate
he had several conversations and meeting
with clark griffith
the owner of the washington senators
according to sam many of those meetings
did not go very well a lot of promises
made
none were ever kept clark griffith made
so much money from renting his stadium
to the homestead graves
that a lot of these owners were against
integration because they knew
if black players were playing for white
major league baseball teams and there
were no more
legally games then they would lose that
significant chunk of revenue that they'd
been earning
but sam was persistent and he wrote a
lot of articles
challenging clark griffith to uphold his
commitment to integrate the game
george kennesaw mountain landis who was
the commissioner of major league
baseball was
very vocal in his stance that as long as
he was commissioner
there was never going to be a black man
playing in the major leagues
in my opinion one of the most racist men
in baseball history
he's on record telling rube foster that
you give our league a black eye when
your teams beat our teams
he had an opportunity to fix the game
early but he refused to accept the
responsibility
and the game was not repaired until he
died in 1944
happy chandler becomes the next
commissioner and happy chandler opens
the door
for jackie robinson to become the first
black player to play in the major
leagues
in major league baseball's organized
history
when we talk about branch rickey signing
jackie robinson
and integrating major league baseball he
pushed for integration in a way
that didn't honor the desires and the
needs of everyone else around him
kansas city monarchs received zero
dollars
they've got nothing for jackie robinson
october of 1945
jackie's deal was announced and spring
of 46
branch rookie signed other players in
addition to jackie robinson branch
rickey
is in their backyard he is continuing to
steal players without honoring the negro
leagues without honoring their contracts
and the negro national league owners
were absolutely livid
he essentially put the negro league
owners between
a rock and a poor house there's no way
that the other owner
can stand up and protest what every
black
baseball fan in america had been waiting
and that was for a black man to play in
the major leagues
emperor manley is the most important
female in baseball history
black or white the first woman to be
inducted into the national baseball hall
of fame
she was the queen of the negro leagues
effa married
abe manly and abe was a huge baseball
fan
so in 1935 he purchased the newark
eagles
from the very beginning he relied on her
to kind of run the business side of
things
as co-owner effa pretty much did
everything except perhaps
player scouting she handled player
contracts and negotiations
she scheduled games she bought uniforms
and equipment
perhaps most importantly she was
responsible for
public relations and community relations
she was constantly trying to figure out
a way to use her platform
with this team to give back to this
community
as they integrated the major leagues
effort held out
i think alpha knew just as well as all
the other owners knew
that baseball's integration was going to
kill the negro leagues
branch rickey not too long after jackie
robinson comes calling for monty irvin
monte irvine was a superstar player well
ethan manley
essentially refused to allow him to be
signed by the brooklyn dodgers
without it being contested she felt like
i have contracts on these men
and if you want them you will pay me she
was criticized by the black press
for hindering integration but she stood
her ground
effa always knew she was going to do
whatever she had to do to make sure that
he had an opportunity to play major
league baseball
so she ended up negotiating with the
owners of the new york giants
they agreed to buy his contract for five
thousand dollars
again far less than what he was actually
worth so essentially jackie's
stolen but she got compensated for
people like larry dovey
her stance in fighting for compensation
for her players
is what essentially opened this up for
other negro league owners
to at least start getting paid for
players who they would then
sell to the major leagues but i think
all the owners at that point in time
realized
that the handwriting was on the wall it
wasn't a matter of if the negro leagues
were going to fold
it was simply a matter of when they were
going to fold